[Music]
Iron Man 3 is directed by Shane black
and stars robert downey jr don cheadle
gwyneth paltrow guy pearce ben kingsley
and rebecca hall i would say that this
is the sequel to iron man 2 but i really
don't think it is it's really the sequel
to THE AVENGERS and in this film you
have Tony Stark grappling with this
villain the Mandarin he's a terrorist
he's causing a lot of different
terrorist attacks on the earth and he's
witnessing all of this the same time
he's having difficulties with his
relationship with one of Paltrow they're
having arguments they're not getting
along well and he is questioning just
how much of him wants to be Iron Man
anymore and so he sets out on a one-man
mission to try to find the Mandarin Iron
Man 3 is a movie that of course I was
looking forward to because you know if
you can't tell the things behind me I am
a nerd I like me some movies and I like
me some superhero movies I really love
the first Iron Man film wasn't a big fan
of Iron Man 2 adored The Avengers I
think that's one of the best superhero
films ever made
and for that reason I was very much
looking forward to Iron Man 3 how is the
movie very good Iron Man 3 is a lot of
fun
of course Downey jr. is back in this
role and you can't really imagine anyone
else playing this guy and he proves that
so well in this film because you get a
lot of sequences in this movie where
it's just Tony Stark there isn't as much
of Iron Man in the suit fighting in this
movie you get a lot of Tony Stark doing
a lot of this on his own having to
scrounge for pieces and parts but a
little bit Dark Knight Rises ish you
know he kind of goes into an area where
he doesn't really have all this
technology at his disposal anymore and
he's supposed to improvise to try to get
himself out of a whole bunch of really
messed up situation at first I was like
you know I'd like to see a little more
Iron Man but you know what I actually
started to like it after a while where
it was more just Tony Stark using his
basic human smarts because he is a
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist and you get a lot in this
movie it's way more of a human film than
any of the other Iron Man films work you
get to learn a lot about Tony Stark in
this movie so when he does put on the
suit it's all the more enthralling don't
worry if you're weary of any spoilers I
won't give any of them away I won't
allude to anything in the film all I'll
say is that there are different elements
of the plot in this movie that could
hinge on whether or not you like it or
not there are certain things that happen
in the film where some comic book fan
especially fans of the Ironman source
material will be very upset and I got to
tell you by far this is the most
different comic book film I've ever seen
this film is in no way like the previous
Iron Man films it's in no way like the
Avengers it's completely different it's
its own film it stands apart from those
very well and some people will be
disappointed by that because this isn't
like a big grand epic action filled
extravaganza until the third act there's
a lot of Tony Stark being Tony Stark and
having to as I said scrounged for like
little scraps of Technology and try to
get out of situations just based off of
his intellect and I kind of like that
about this movie there was a part of me
that wanted more action that wanted more
big set pieces you get them in this film
there's a lot of that in this movie and
this movie is very clever and extremely
funny too I think it's actually probably
the funniest Iron Man movie out of the
three that we've had but you can really
feel Shane black the director in there
he wrote Kiss Kiss Bang Bang also with
Robert Downey jr. and he was also
Hawkins in predator if you didn't know
that which is interesting to me but
anyway you can really feel him behind
this movie because there are certain
elements of the screenplay that just
feels so different and there are certain
elements that didn't work for me for one
certain things happen in the movie that
were so easily explained and these
things were like extremely big plot
points in the first two films like how
are we gonna do this how we're gonna do
that and this film is sort of kind of
brushed them apart I can't really get
into it but there were certain elements
of the story that didn't always work
about the first 20 minutes of this film
I was like are we gonna get going here
and it did start a little bit slow and I
was disappointed by that certain
characters in the movie are very very
underdeveloped back around people who
seem like they're important to the story
but the characters aren't really that
well-developed
there were certain times during the
movie when I was watching and I was like
really this is what they're doing this
is the direction they're taking and it
seems odd you know but then when you
look back on the movie you can go like
you know okay I can't I guess that kind
of makes sense and it's because there
are certain things once again without
spoiling that this movie does that you
don't really think it's going to do but
then when you look back on their film
and think about how they set up certain
things it makes sense that eventually
that happened because they were saying
it up that way that's you know it's a
little hard to explain and I apologize I
really can't get into it without
spoiling it I just can't but I tried I
really did I can't spoil it for you so I
won't but I guarantee certain hardcore
comic book
of Iron Man are going to be disappointed
by certain things as a film structurally
it holds together pretty well there are
a lot of really great set pieces in this
movie it's very funny there's really
great special effects the score is good
there's a lot of great relationships
between Robert Downey jr. and other
characters Don Cheadle I thought was
much better in this film that he was an
Iron Man to his character was cooler I
liked his presence a lot more than an
Iron Man - I like that they drew back
from the hole I'm an awesome Playboy and
ever I'm better than everyone kind of
thing like he has that still as a
character but it was less abrasive like
it was an Iron Man - as all villains do
in movies they all have their little
cohorts you know like there's the main
phone and they have their little cronies
I didn't really like the the cronies in
this movie there were these guys that
helped out the Mandarin and everything
and I just felt like they were sort of
just there they just seemed like drones
really even though they were living
people and I didn't really like that in
this movie Ben Kingsley is very good in
the film guy Pierce is very good in the
film Rebecca Hall's character is very
underdeveloped and despite the fact
she's a good actress I didn't really
feel like her character had much to do
in the movie you go to see Iron Man for
Iron Man Robert Downey jr. and he was
great in this movie what some people may
look at as a shortage of action
sequences during the second act of this
movie I looked at as a way to build the
character and there was still
substantial action scenes it just it was
Tony Stark doing it and I really liked
that it took the film in a different
direction despite the fact that it would
have been cool I guess to see a little
more Iron Man that's just the boy in me
wanting to see more Iron Man though but
overall I really enjoyed Iron Man 3 I
think that it is much better than Iron
Man 2 I still like Iron Man one more and
I like the Avengers more you just ki
can't beat the Avengers this movie is
not like the Avengers at all so please
when you go in to Iron Man 3 do not
expect it to be as epic or just to
mungus as the Avengers was this is a
very different type of film but I think
it does what it tries to do very well
I'm gonna give IMM 3 a B+ there are some
problems in the story elements certain
characters are underdeveloped as I said
hardcore fans of the comics are probably
going to find some things to be upset
about in this film understandably so
nevertheless I would recommend seeing
Iron Man 3 if you want to have a good
time at the movies thanks for watching
guys as always and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck
menage
[Music]